there are filmmakers whose projects feel
like mandatory viewing and I think it's
safe to say that Nolan is one of them I
mean next to the word thought-provoking
in the dictionary is Christopher Nolan's
movies just think back to the time that
you finished the movie Inception I mean
I'm still trying to figure out what went
on in tenant Chris's projects have
always had a unique feel based in
Practical effects along with some
seriously talented actors that bring his
Visions to life so to help make the case
for Nolan whose latest Oppenheimer has
finally hit theaters here's a list of
his best movies by Tomato Meter right
now on Rotten Tomatoes countdown
thank you
starting with number 10 Interstellar
this 2014 certified fresh film was
directed co-written and produced by
Christopher Nolan which are the same
roles that he pretty much has on every
single film he does it's set in a
dystopian future where a group of
astronauts travel through a wormhole in
search of a new home for Humanity I mean
can I come get me out of here the film
feature is big I mean huge names like
Matthew McConaughey Anne Hathaway Matt
Damon and Jessica Chastain but what
really resonated with fans were these
Stellar visuals brought to life by Nolan
I mean it feels like they actually shot
this in space apparently do not open the
inner hatch I repeat do not Brandon
but I'm taking command of the endurance
talk about completing the mission
Dr Mann listen to me this is not about
my life
for Cooper's life this is about all
mankind
there is a moment
his nuts
and that's a big reason why it made over
677 million dollars at the global box
office and has picked up a bit of a
Sci-Fi cult following plus it received
five Oscar Noms winning one for best
visual effects obviously
number nine The Prestige
2006 was actually a big year for movies
about magic and magicians pretty
randomly and that included this mystery
drama based on the 1995 novel of the
same name by Christopher priest now
Nolan wrote this film with his brother
Jonathan Nolan and it follows two 19th
century magicians in a battle for
Supremacy played by Christian Bale and
Hugh Jackman the film reunited Nolan
with Christian Bale after making Batman
Begins together the previous year and
let's just say it was definitely a
change of pace for both of them
look
shoot me I see you go on shoot me
right there no I can't no no not there
shoot me here
how's that
it's very cute tell me how you do it
well then you can't do it I can't do it
do it and while it's certified fresh 76
Tomato Meter score is solid a 92
audience score is really where it's at I
mean the people have spoken
number eight Batman Begins
directed by you guessed it Christopher
Nolan who co-wrote it with David S goyer
this served as a reboot for the Batman
film series coming less than a decade
after George Clooney donned the nipple
cape in Batman and Robin I mean I'm
gonna get drag for saying this but
nipple suit Batman is one of my
favorites and I gotta say Clooney really
did make a great Bruce Wayne but back to
Batman Begins Nolan was aiming for a
darker more realistic tone to get the
audience more invested in both the
Batman and Bruce Wayne characters he
also wanted to tell an origin story that
no one had ever really seen before which
included a look at Batman's actual
training and it turns out Bruce Wayne
wasn't just some rich guy taking a bunch
of karate classes anger does not change
the fact that your father failed to act
the man had a gun did that stop you
that's that dream the training is
nothing
[Music]
the will to act
yield in true Nolan Fashion but somewhat
unorthodox for big budget superhero
movies was his Reliance on traditional
stunts and miniature effects and less on
CGI and hey it worked I mean as
evidenced by a strong box office showing
and an Oscar nom for best cinematography
not to mention it kicked off one hell of
a popular trilogy
number seven Inception
now this one was written and directed by
Christopher Nolan who also produced it
along with his wife Emma Thomas and I
just love how much he loves to work with
his family now this is actually somewhat
inspiring Nolan actually first wrote a
script around this concept back in 2002
after he completed insomnia but later
realized that he needed more big budget
features under his belt before he could
tackle this one and when the time
finally came he tapped Leonardo DiCaprio
to play the lead after wanting to work
with him for some time DiCaprio of
course came on board because he was
interested in the concept and Nolan
actually worked on tweaking the script
to make sure Leo's character and his
emotional Journey were the driving force
along with you know the crazy visuals so
how did we end up here
well we just came from the uh
where are you
We're Dreaming you're actually in the
middle of the workshop right now
sleeping this is your first lesson and
shared dreaming stay calm foreign
[Music]
now along with Leo is another strong
cast with names like Joseph
Gordon-Levitt Marianne katiard Elliot
page Tom Hardy and Killian Murphy many
of whom Nolan has worked with repeatedly
and you may already know this but
Inception crush it at the box office
with over 828 million dollars worldwide
good enough for the fourth highest
grossing film of 2010. it also happened
to earn eight Oscar nominations
including one for best picture and took
home four including best cinematography
and best visual effects I mean with Leo
and zasara gets my best visuals award
moving on
number six The Dark Knight Rises
now this film marks the final
installment in Christopher Nolan's Dark
Knight trilogy and it takes place eight
years after the event of The Dark Knight
while introducing the villain Bane
played by none other than Tom Hardy back
for a third installment didn't actually
excite Christopher Nolan all that much
at first he was like come on guys I'm
just kidding until he and his co-writer
slash brother Jonathan Nolan came up
with what they would consider to be a
suitable end to the series and no one
actually pulled from various comic book
storylines for this movie including
Bane's debut in 1993's Nightfall
storyline and I gotta say one thing is
for sure Batman definitely met his match
with Bane
oh you think darkness is your ally
are you merely adopted the dark
I was born in it
molded by it
I didn't see the light until I was
already a man but then it was nothing to
me but Brighton
the Shadows betray you
cause they belong to me the certified
fresh film also has an audience score at
90 percent and the consensus from
critics reads that The Dark Knight Rises
quote concludes Nolan's franchise in
spectacular fashion
let's take a look at our list so far of
the best Christopher Nolan movies can
you wrap your mind around which film is
in our number one spot
[Music]
number five insomnia
this marked the third feature-length
film for director Christopher Nolan and
the only one of his career so far that
he isn't credited as writer or co-writer
with that honor going to Hillary sites
for this one insomnia is a remake of a
1997 Norwegian movie of the same name
with this version starring Al Pacino
Robin Williams and Hilary swing and it
follows two La homicide detectives
investigating a murder in Alaska and I
gotta say I am a sucker for a Pacino
interrogation on screen Randy
foreign
it might even work with a couple of
these local cops who've known you long
enough to figure you're too dumb ever to
kill anyone without leaving a couple of
witnesses and assigned confession
ain't gonna work with me
number four Dunkirk
this 2017 film was written directed and
produced by Nolan and depicts the
Dunkirk evacuation of World War II from
the perspectives of sea land and air
Nolan and his team created most of the
suspense with music and cinematography
finding a way to put IMAX cameras on the
wings of planes and do it safely they
also dressed up a two-seater jet called
a yak 52 which is my new favorite name
for anything to look like the
single-seater Spitfire but with room for
a camera to film The Pilot in action but
enough mumbo jumbo for me I mean check
out this clip
it's no wonder Dunkirk was such a slam
dunk at the Oscars picking up eight
nominations including best picture and
best director and taking home three
statues for best sound editing sound
mixing and film editing and it includes
an appearance from the Harry Styles
therefore getting another visuals award
from me
okay number three memento
Noir psychological Thriller was written
and directed by Nolan and based on the
short story Memento Mori by his brother
Jonathan Nolan and I bet he was all like
a cool story bro no seriously let's make
a movie about this now in IT guy pure
stars as a man trying to hunt down his
wife's killer while suffering from
short-term memory loss so he uses an
elaborate system of tattoos written
notes and Polaroid photos
how long have I been looking
find anything
didn't think so
let's go huh
you're gonna pay for what you did Big
forgiveness
you know
clue you freak beg my wife's forgiveness
your brains out the unique story and
approach to telling it quickly landed
Christopher Nolan on the map in just his
second film I mean the 94 audience score
is a testament to the cult following
this film has built over the years and
it's certified fresh 93 Tomato Meter
score is backed by a consensus that says
quote Nolan skillfully guides the
audience through memento's fractured
narrative seeping his film in
existential dread Chris if you need any
more essential dread I got plenty more
with that guy from
number two The Dark Knight
no surprise here this film is the second
installment of Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy following 2005's Batman Begins
and some of Nolan's Inspirations for
this film included the Joker's comic
book debut in 1940 and the 1988 graphic
novel The Killing Joke and we all know
that one of the main reasons this movie
stands Above the Rest both other Nolan
Batman films and Beyond is the late
Heath Ledger as the Joker the worst end
those mob fools want you gone so they
can get back to the way things were
but I know the truth there's no going
back you've changed things
forever then why do you want to kill me
I don't want to kill you what would I do
without you go back to ripping off mob
dealers no no
you
you were complete me Ledger actually
died a few months after he completed
filming and six months before the
movie's release but was posthumously
awarded a best supporting actor Oscar
for his performance The Dark Knight
became the highest grossing film of 2008
with over a billion dollars earned and
also tallied eight Oscar nominations
winning one for best sound editing plus
it was selected for preservation in the
National film registry as just the
second superhero film to earn that honor
after 1978 Superman I mean how cool is
that
number one Oppenheimer
now once again written produced and
directed by the trifecta that is
Christopher Nolan this film stars
Killian Murphy as J Robert Oppenheimer a
theoretical physicist who is considered
to be the father of the atomic bomb the
star-studded cast also includes folks
like Emily Blunt Matt Damon Rami Malek
Robert Downey Jr Josh Hartnett Casey
Affleck and Kenneth Branagh in
supporting roles I mean Enough stars to
form a Galaxy I don't know if that makes
sense but it sounds right in my head
[Music]
we imagine a future
and our imaginings horrify us
they won't fear it
until they understand it
then they won't understand it
until they've used it now Oppenheimer is
based on a 2005 biography called
American Prometheus and Nolan actually
wrote the script in first person
something he's never done before to try
and put people in oppenheimer's shoes
because of this film Chris actually
became one of the first directors to
dabble in IMAX black and white
photography for this film to help add to
the overall effect I mean he loves to
experiment and we love to watch it
all right my friends that is Nolan's
list now let's all go try and live our
lives with a little less CGI and a
little more practicality for more on all
these movies that we discussed today be
sure to hit up right
hom thank you so much for checking out
today's list until next time I am your
host Naz Perez and we'll see you back
here for more Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
thank you